[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Morgan is
in Minneapolis hi Morgan welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my calls
sure what's up
um so I have sort of a complicated
situation
um my husband and I are in the middle of
a construction project that should be
wrapping up here
hopefully in the next few weeks but my
question is in the meantime should we
work the debt snowball or should we try
to attack our credit card debt which is
at the end of our debt snowball
um to improve our credit scores in the
meantime since we have to maintain good
credit before we refinance
you have a construction loan
yes you've not been pre-approved for
your takeout loan
no not yet why how in the world did you
get the construction line without a
pre-approved takeout
that's weird well you don't have your
permanent mortgage arranged
um I mean
well that would be not
yeah
okay oh my gosh I'm scared
um what's causing that I don't know how
they got their construction loan very
few people will make a construction loan
I mean what is y'all's net worth
Morgan
I don't know the answer to that right
offhand okay you don't have anything but
you don't have any money because you
have a bunch of credit card debt how
much credit card debt do you have
um just about twenty thousand and I
think most of that relates to our
project yeah I bet and what's your
household income
under a hundred thousand
okay and what is what do you owe on the
construction loan
um slightly over 300.
goodness other debt any other debt
yes um we have
um 20.
let's see trying to think here about 30
000 in student loans
okay are you current with everything
right now
yes we are okay this week go to
Churchill Mortgage yes and arrange for
your mortgage right now
okay because this house of cards may
fall in
and if it does you're going to lose this
house
and I want you to get your I want you to
get your permanent Mortgage in place
before this crap falls apart
okay because you have gotten yourself
into deep debt
and I'm I'm really afraid for you right
now you took on an awfully big mortgage
and you overran the budget on the
project and you did not have a backdoor
plan with in place with your takeout
mortgage and so you're in a very tenuous
situation so the first thing you've got
to do is immediately get a mortgage in
place to take out set up and approved to
take out this construction loan and then
once it's approved it won't be a problem
as long as you do it in the next 30 days
you're going to be finished with a
project you said in a couple of weeks
right
yep okay so you can get your Uno and get
your appraisal done and you guys can
close you know like by the end of the
month or early next month and be done
inside of 30 days here you got to get
your mortgage in place once that's done
then we just start working on this the
debt snowball with the student loan and
the credit cards but you're in a very
tenuous place because if you stub your
toe before you get approval on this
permanent and I'm worried about you
getting approval you got a really big
mortgage based on your income
but if you can get approval you don't
want to stub your toe you don't want to
miss you know these stinking student
loans that they're due October 1st so
you got to have something in place to
pay that student loan payment October
1st and you got to make sure all your
credit cards are paid on time between
now and then so you guys need to lay out
a detailed budget not miss a stinking
thing until you get this permanent in
place once the permanent mortgage is in
place then we'll back up breathe a
little bit and start attacking the rest
of these debts but you've left yourself
very very vulnerable here because if one
little thing goes sideways you don't pay
a credit card on time uh you're not
going to get up because you got a real
tight permanent mortgage that your
ratios are questionable as it is yeah
and um you get a mess girl that is a
mess yeah you guys completely uh jumped
in the deep end and not swimming so good
so you got to really really be careful
with that it's scary so Jay the thing
you should always do number one you
shouldn't be building a house if you got
credit card debt number two you should
stay within budget so you don't run up
credit cards to make the budget because
you went over budget on your house
because you didn't keep up with your dad
gum numbers I'm building the house right
now the Builder just sent me the
spreadsheet on what we've actually spent
versus budget and it's pretty simple
formula yeah here's what we budgeted
here's what we've spent we're under
budget we're over budget and you can
keep track of that every stinking week
with a builder if they've got their uh
stuff together okay so
and uh then you don't go for butt and
you don't pick stuff that doesn't fit
you know in the budget you know so no
you can't have that carpet no you can't
have that tile and know that Appliance
isn't going in the kitchen you know you
don't have the budget that's not what
we're doing I mean Sharon's in our case
if we decide to break the budget because
we see something we want to do we can do
that but we're doing that amongst a
bunch of information that gives us uh
the ability to make that decision wisely
what what causes them to not take out
that take over that construction loan
earlier
you can't get a permanent mortgage on a
house that doesn't have a Uno use an
occupancy permit if the house isn't
completed they won't make a traditional
so it's that they're overtime and over
they're over not just over 100 they're
over time as well no no they have to
finish you you could get the
you can get the takeout mortgage
approved subject to completion before
you break ground
before you can start the house okay and
that's what should have happened but
since they didn't do that uh they can't
get a mortgage in place and pay off the
construction loan so the mortgage won't
be funded to pay off the construction
loan until completion
but you can get it all approved and
lined up and then if something goes
sideways it doesn't matter already
approved okay they don't revisit and
reapprove the mortgage six times during
the build they approve it one time give
you a letter says you're approved and at
completion we're going to fund the
mortgage that's simple and uh but you
can get in a real pinch in a situation
like this because they're good because
that bank is going to want their money
when the house is completed yeah and you
don't have a permanent
you're in foreclosure instantly they're
gonna want their money
and so you got to get a permanent and
you got to get it up for sale one of the
two
and uh boy that'd be sad